good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight we take a lot of digs at the
media on this show and we do it for two
reasons
it's fun and they deserve it recently
we've watched with growing
amusement as our media gatekeepers
thrash around in a frenzy of foaming
hysteria
over the possibility that someone
somewhere might dare to present
facts or form opinions without their
express written permission
freelance thinking is what they hate
most it's a threat to their monopoly
they can't say that out loud so instead
they call it disinformation
disinformation is the real threat says
the guy who thinks his union has the
contract on bringing you the news
it's ridiculous but before you judge
these people take a moment and feel some
compassion consider how they might be
feeling
right about now imagine if you had spent
30 years making a good living as a car
mechanic
and all of a sudden gm invents an engine
that anyone can fix
at home with a screwdriver you'd be
upset that's how cnn feels about the
internet
it's exposing their scam naturally
they're a little irrational about it
millions of americans clinging to
conspiracy theories
this is all evidence of radicalization
and that's not easy to say it's not an
easy word to use
but it's way past time to talk about
this honestly no one should tiptoe
past this predicament disinformation
networks like q and on
are causing people to lose touch with
reality
disinformation networks that doesn't
sound like a misleading social media
post
it sounds like a terror cell and it
sounds that way on purpose
the thing about disinformation they're
telling us is that it's not simply
harmful to you personally it's not like
eating a pint of ben and jerry's or
sneaking a smoke while the kids are at
school no this information isn't a sin
it's a crime
disinformation hurts everyone it's an
offense against this country
disinformation is an attack on america
and not just on america
but more critically on something called
our norms
our norms are so out of whack that it
has become surprising when good things
happen
even after four years of us talking you
know night after night
about the norms that are being shattered
he is doing
everything to shred every one of these
norms
we can't allow these kind of democratic
norms to be shattered
so we abided by these norms but this
president is just real in this
administration
just blown right through those norms not
since the red scare
uh have once good men and women been
dragged into this kind of sabotage
of our democracy and social norms
our norms shattered shredded
crushed destroyed blown through
why is it always our norms that are the
first to be attacked
maybe because our norms are democracy's
first responders they run to the sound
of gunfire
norms are like the young lieutenants in
vietnam walking point through the rice
paddies
exposing themselves to fire in order to
save the platoon
it's a dangerous job being in norm and
never more so than now
you thought underwater welding was a
treacherous gig you feared for the guys
who fix antennas on skyscrapers that's
nothing
imagine being a norm in today's america
they don't last long
okay we'll stop it's all pretty amusing
and it's hard to resist our norms our
norms
on the other hand if we're being
completely honest here and we strive to
be completely honest we have to admit
there is a kernel of truth in what
they're yelling about
there is disinformation out there and it
does hurt people
makes people stupid for one thing but it
also impairs their ability to make wise
decisions
you can't know what to do next if you
don't know what's really going on
a lot of people in this country are in
that position right now we saw evidence
of it
just this week we read a research paper
called how informed are americans about
race and policing
it was published by the skeptic research
center check it out online if you have a
minute it's a pretty amazing document
the researchers asked people to estimate
the number of unarmed african americans
who were killed by the police in 2019
hear the results 44 percent of americans
who describe themselves as
liberal believe the total number of
killed was quote
a thousand or more more than a thousand
unarmed african americans gunned down by
cops is that true
well as it happened we have definitive
statistics on this they're publicly
available you could find them in about a
minute
the actual number of unarmed
african-americans killed by the police
in 2019
was 27. so more than a thousand
versus the reality of 27 quite a spread
and it was not an anomaly the rest of
the study found similar results
self-described liberals for example
believe that a strong majority of people
killed by police in 2019 were african
americans
the actual percentage was less than half
that closer to 25 percent
these are not small mistakes a lot of
americans are completely and utterly
misinformed and that has
actual consequences public policy can
change dramatically in the basis
of things people think they know but
don't actually know and we have seen
that a lot
entire police departments got defunded
so it's worth finding out where the
public is getting all this false
information this
disinformation as we'll call it so we
checked
we spent all day trying to locate the
famous q anon
which in the end we learned is not even
a website if it's out there we could not
find it
then we checked marjorie taylor green's
twitter feed because we have heard she
trafficks in disinformation scene and
told us
but nothing there next we called our
many friends in the tight-knit intel
community
could vladimir putin be putting this
stuff out there the proud boys
alex jones who is lying to america in
ways that are certain to make us hate
each other
and certain to destroy our core
institutions well none of the above
actually it wasn't marjorie taylor green
it was cable news it was politicians
talking on tv
they're the ones spreading
disinformation to americans
maybe they're from q anon you be the
judge
we have a long and wretched and
disturbing history in this country
of black people being murdered
by law enforcement training for police
officers
on implicit racial bias and procedural
justice because to deny it exist is to
deny folks
liberty and in many cases life how can
we continue to lose the lives of unarmed
black men
in the united states of america at the
hands of white police officers
i never had to tell my daughter if she's
pulled over
make sure she puts for a traffic stop
put both hands on top of the wheel
and don't reach for the glove box
because someone may shoot you
so not only are huge numbers of unarmed
african americans murdered every year
because of their race
to deny that or question that fact is to
effectively participate in those
killings yourself denying this is
denying them
life as kamala harris put it or as cnn
said
it's mass murder no i'm not telling
people to go out there and ride
but tell me what the proportional
response to mass murder over the years
is what is a proportional response to
that
i'm not telling people to go out and
riot but what is the proportional
response to mass murder
good question cnn burning wendy's
obviously
but where you ask and this is the
missing piece of the puzzle are all the
victims of this indiscriminate racial
violence
well in january msnbc was pretty sure
they had found one
the channel claimed cops had tried to
execute an unarmed african-american man
called jacob blake in wisconsin
and they repeated that claim that jacob
blake was unarmed again
and again and again no charges will be
brought against the police officer
or any of the police officers involved
in the shooting of jacob blake he was an
unarmed black man
who was shot viewers may recall an
officer shot blake in the back
seven times while he was unarmed
another example of african-americans
not receiving equal protection of law
mr blake was unarmed at the time that he
was
shot so it's sad that jacob blake got
shot sincerely it's always
sad when people get shot whether you
agree with him or not
period but why jacob blake was shot is
kind of the whole point of the story
isn't it mr blake was unarmed at the
time he was shot that's what they told
us again and again
and yet someone in msnbc's news division
forgot to check with jacob blake about
that because a week later
jacob blake himself admitted on camera
that he was in fact armed
i'm rattled you know i realized i had
dropped my knife
had a little pocket knife so i picked it
up after i got off of him
because they tased me and i fell on top
of him
i shouldn't have picked it up
only considering what was going on at
that time i wasn't thinking
clearly oh just to be totally clear we
feel sorry for jacob lee
he got hurt it'll change his life
forever but it's not quite the neat
little morality tale
we thought it was is it and again we're
not telling you that we're not
correcting
the lie because we're smug and
self-satisfied and enjoy highlighting
the other
people's errors we're just defending our
norms here as any american would are we
heroes for doing that
we can't say so it just feels like the
right thing to do
but it is a never-ending task we could
give you many examples here's one from
the weekend
hundreds of activists gathered in new
york to stage a march against white
nationalism
they said they were seeking justice for
an 84 year old man from thailand
who had been slashed with a box cutter
on the subway a lot of violence on the
new york subway right now here's one
example
protesters stormed through washington
square park chaining slogans like whose
streets are streets
one held a sign that read white
nationalism is the virus
well maybe it is the virus but it's hard
to know exactly who's been infected with
it
police have now arrested a 19 year old
man called antoine watson for the crime
let's just say it's hard to imagine that
antoine watson is a white supremacist
so why are they suggesting otherwise
what is all of this about
well here's an interesting theory and it
comes to us from a researcher called
zach goldberg who does not work at cnn
by the way
goldberg looked at every time the term
racism was used in america's largest
newspapers and he noticed
a trend in fact there was a noticeable
spike just
after 2011 which not coincidentally
was right around the time of the occupy
wall street movement
when people are starting to talk about
what wall street actually does in public
suddenly all at once journalists agreed
that the real problem in america
is it's racism america is not a
place with a screwed up economic system
that rewards a tiny number of
emotionally damaged grifters
who possess otherwise useless skills
applicable only to finance in pai gow
a place where everyone else gets poor
people with real jobs are making less
people in finance are making more but
that's not a problem
oh no stop talking about it immediately
and that's an order
no america is instead we learned a place
where the rest of us must hate each
other
at all times because of our skin colors
which by the way cannot be changed
and that way once we're all yelling and
aggrieved and angry about irresolvable
race questions
once we've picked the wound until it
won't stop bleeding we won't have the
time to ask even the most basic
questions about economics
questions like why are all these
billionaire hedge fund guys paying half
the tax rate i am
and who precisely is getting rich from
the federal reserve where's all that
money going
it'd be nice to know but you don't see a
ton of stories about those questions in
the new york times
they're too busy talking about race it's
a pretty sophisticated
operation this cover wall street op if
you think about it
vladimir putin could never pull it off
he'd buy a few dopey ads on facebook and
call it a day home to his vodka and
bears
no it takes a sophisticated operator to
lie this effectively
to take the central problem of american
life which is the agonizing death of our
middle class
and cover it with a smoke screen of
manufactured race hatred
so that no one even realizes it's
happening
you'd really need to be a well a cnn
would put a disinformation network to
pull that off
and of course the irony is because
everything is irony is that cnn itself
has become a disinformation network more
powerful than queuing on and far more
destructive
you gotta wonder if jeff zucker's ever
get hauled up to congress to ask for
that